NARRATOR: In this
video, we're going
to walk through how
to manage member
permissions for your Google
Cloud billing account.
To manage member
permissions, you'll
need to be a Billing Account
Administrator on the billing
account.
Get started by heading
into the Console,
then head to the Navigation
menu in the left-hand pane.
Choose Billing.
Then use the drop-down menu to
select Manage Billing Accounts.
Select the billing
account for which
you'd like to manage
members and permissions.
This will open
the Overview page.
In the left hand nav,
choose Account Management.
To the right, you will
see the info panel
where you can view the
list of current members,
edit their permissions,
or remove them.
You can also add new members.
Permissions are bundled to
form several functional roles.
Billing Account Administrators
can view cost information, link
and unlink projects
from the account,
and manage other member
roles on the account.
They are also the only
ones who can contact Google
Cloud support if you need help.
Billing Account Costs
Managers can view all cost
details, including project costs
and non-project related costs,
such as the cost of
support or subscriptions.
They can also manage budgets
and export cost information
to BigQuery for analysis.
Billing Account Viewers
can view all cost details
for the billing account and
view, but not edit, budgets
and BigQuery export settings.
Billing Account Users
can link projects
with the billing account.
These role assignments are made
at the billing account level.
However, there are also
billing-related roles
at the organization,
folder, and project levels.
You can set roles
at these levels
by navigating to the project,
folder, or organization
from the project selector,
and then to the IAM page,
where you can view
current members
and add new members and roles.
At the project or folder
level, Project Billing Managers
can assign a project's
billing account
when they have the billing
account user role on the target
billing account.
They can also disable
a project's billing.
At the organization level,
Billing Account Creators
can create new self-serve
billing accounts.
It is a good idea to minimize
the number of members
who have this role in
order to better manage
your organization's
billing accounts and spend.
You can also set the roles
that we discussed earlier,
such as Billing Account
Administrator, User, and Viewer
at the organization
level and the permissions
will apply to all the Cloud
billing accounts, projects,
and resources in
the organization.
Head over to the documentation
to check out more details.